trente millions de touristes par an 20
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
sans 48 mille emplois la région paca
compte sur les étrangers pour faire
vivre son économie fortement impacté par
la crise du coc vite 19 les
professionnels du tourisme multiplie les
initiatives
chaque vacance communication massive
mais ces mesures demeurent insuffisantes
le grand hôtel des sablettes hilton à la
seyne-sur-mer dans le var emploi en
temps normal 70 salariés pour un taux
d'occupation de 50 à 60% à cette période
de l'année
mais depuis octobre une dizaine
d'employés suffisent à prendre en charge
les touristes alors que la saison
estivale avait été plutôt fructueuse dès
la fin août
l'allemagne et la belgique ont classé
plusieurs départements de la région en
zone à risque entraînant ainsi une
baisse de la fréquentation depuis le 1er
janvier le directeur de l'établissement
déplore jusqu'à 60 % de perte pour lui
la mise en place d'un passeport
vaccinale serait une des solutions à
envisager pour une reprise de l'activité
le passeport vaccinale il existe déjà
dans l'industrie touristique
quand on se déplace quand les mecs quand
les français vont en afrique qui se font
les prisons ils sont extrêmement complet
palu et donc vérifier alors arrivé
qu'ils ont pris la fièvre jaune et c'est
donc cette année on fait face à une
pandémie coronavirus il faut trouver des
solutions le passeport avec semelle en
est une il faut peut-être la mettre en
place l'auberge sur le port
établissement prisé de bandol est fermé
comme tous les autres restaurants son
propriétaire également président de
l'union des métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie du var est lui plus mitigé
sur le passeport vaccinale
c'est quand même discriminatoire c'est
difficile des pieds nous on sait très
policé on n'est pas des services de
police on peut pas avoir une attitude de
contrôle et puis je pense que les
français devraient faire vacciner
davantage l'instauration d'un
laissez-passer vaccinale pour voyager
accéder aux restaurants ou salles de
concerts en france l'idée fait débat
jugé inopportun par certains prématuré
pour d'eau
certains pays comme la grèce l'espagne
l'italie l'autriche où le danemark
plaide néanmoins en sa faveur dans
l'hexagone le conseil économique social
et environnemental a d'ailleurs lancé ce
mercredi une consultation en ligne sur
le sujet les français ont jusqu'au 7
mars pour y répondre